vous connaissez l'expression une
hirondelle ne fait pas le printemps mais
on doit on ajouter une autre un sondage
ne fait pas le printemps enfin je
regardais encore ce matin les sondages
il ya cinq ans qui donnait alain juppé
marine le pen entre 27 et 30 % sait très
bien ce qu'il en a été d'un à juppé qui
a été éliminée dans le cadre de la
primaire et marine le pen qui a fait
beaucoup moins à la fin donc je crois
qu'il faut regarder tout ça avec
beaucoup de sérénité beaucoup de
prudence et beaucoup de recul d'autant
plus que chez les républicains n'avons
pas encore effectivement encore notre
notre candidat mais les choses viendront
en leur temps ce soir nous avons un
bureau politique nous allons valider la
date du 4 décembre la date aussi du 13
octobre pour le dépôt des candidatures
les dates de dépôt des des parrainages
le processus est enclenché chez nous et
bien évidemment on va mettre à profit ce
moment qui nous séparent du 4 décembre
pour que nos candidats puissent mettre
en avant l'heure leurs propositions et
organiser le débat autour des
propositions des républicains autour de
deux candidats qui sont de grands
talents